yeah i think the thing about now is
it's a real test for the media for
journalists and reporters like me
i'm like stick to the facts
to the data follow the experts follow
the election commission
nurse and all the people that are
actually putting this on on the ground
instead of trying to guesstimate um i
think
you know there are places where
president trump over performed or
brought biden underperformed
um florida being one of those places
right that was when you talk about an
unexpected result
um that was when they were feeling kind
of confident about but the thing that
biden and when you talk to biden people
now even late last night when things
started looking
kind of shaky is that this is what they
were actually expecting for months
we kept hearing that you know this is
gonna be a blowout you know politico did
not say that
um this is gonna be a blowout um there's
gonna be a huge repudiation of president
trump
that is not what we have seen i think no
matter what happens with this election
at the end of the day president trump
was able to convince
enough people in this country that their
lived experience right their lived
experience during a pandemic during a
recession
is not reality right like he was able to
convince enough people
that you know covert 19 we were rounding
the corner
i handled it well you know this is the
best economy i've done i've had the best
economy i'm the best for black people
i'm the best for latinos i'm the best
for women
um he was able to convince them of that
and what that means
is that the republican party may not
even if trump loses
the republican party is not going to
just you know
wash their hands of trumpism right in a
way that
joe biden i think was hoping something
that andrew yang said
um to me before is that
you know trump during the primary that
there are some of
the people running i think he's talking
about joe biden that think that
president trump is like
um an interlude right like he is he is
he is a symptom of the problem of phase
right exactly
and that is clearly not the case right
like if there had been this huge
repudiation
around the country um in huge numbers of
president trump if all of the
early vote was just to joe biden that's
what we
would have been saying but that's not
the case and i think how this country
wrestles with that
is going to be fascinating and scary for
a lot of people for
for for you know at least maybe a decade
i think
i feel like your predictions are
probably pretty close to
zach and eyes to be honest in terms of
but but i'm curious really curious as to
you know what um you know there was one
or many
predictions going into election night
that you were personally surprised by
seeing as an outcome
yeah i'm surprised
about georgia georgia is still really
close in a way that i really i just
never believed that um you know
democrats were going to be able to
really play there and i think
they are showing that something's
happening in georgia florida
the latino vote in florida is really
surprising miami
miami hello that underperforming by joe
biden there
is um surprising to us and also i think
super concerning for democrats moving
forward
because there have ever since you know
ever since he was the
general election candidate joe biden um
and the nominee
though you talked to democrats in
florida you talked to latino activists
and they said
he needs to focus on latinos a lot more
he needs to focus on latinos a lot more
and they
didn't really take that seriously they
started to do that toward the end
but it was clearly not enough right and
that is something that
you know you look at the people that
were at the dnc
um julian castro not there you know what
i mean like people
the huge latino names were not a part of
that
process and part of that pageantry and
that matters and i think it showed that
it mattered in
florida more than democrats thought it
was going to there were
so many the only way i can explain it is
just bs
media narratives that came out of the
the hype up this election and i'll give
political credit they weren't
fueling the fire anywhere near as much
as some of maybe the broadcast networks
and things like that
um but we all got wrapped up in it um
itself included but it was
um in some in some ways but there were
narratives like
texas is in play and iowa's in play and
south carolina is in play and
the narratives were fueling these uh
frankly down ballot candidates too
um and they were look jamie harrison
who's the guy who
tret um was running against lindsey
graham raised more money than he could
ever more than we did on the
presidential campaign we raised a lot
and there were polls showing him close
um to almost winning
and then like literally could not have
been further from the truth like they
called it on election night
um pretty early so what
what is the media missing um from your
angle you know what i'm saying like what
is it polling is it headlines it
clickbait
what's driving this i you know
the i'm lucky to work at political a
place that doesn't
you know some you know we don't always
get it right even i know that all right
there's no that like when it comes to
headlines and quick baby things
um but there is so much
the the media issue is that we are
obsessed with drama
we are drama queens we are messy people
who love drama and that is like
at the core of what it seems like is
driving a lot of the media narrative and
the media conversations that
you know um we take one
thing one poll a couple of polls
happening in one state and we pull that
out to me like oh my god the election is
election is not even close this is going
to be a blowout um
it's dangerous it is
you know at times really it's
disconcerting
for democracy because if there isn't a
media that can understand
the people right like if there's an
isn't a media that can understand
how people are feeling in this country
we're kind of screwed right
i think that we i think more times than
not we get we are correct right like i
think
all the reporters i know and the more
i'm in this business the more i
get to meet and the bigger names i you
know that feels like a brag it kind of
is a humble break i guess i get to know
this i get to meet the same thing
yeah yeah like you meet more important
people who have been doing this for a
really long time
so i i have never met a reporter that
like just likes the drama to like the
drama or
isn't doesn't take this part of their
job really seriously right
understanding the american people um and
that's key and i think that part is what
we're losing the polling
industry is doing a i'm going to get in
trouble for this one the public industry
sometimes is doing a better job
of kind of explaining what they got
wrong than kind of getting things right
and so
um in 2016 a lot of the surprise that we
had
was that there was you know they didn't
wait for education
in this country and if you were someone
who was watching 2016 as much as i was
as a reporter
you could tell that something was
happening with
people without white people without a
college degree right that that was
something that
was happening with president trump and
that and so
doing that understanding the different
demographics understanding that latinos
are
not a monolith that black people are not
a monolith asian americans are not a
monolith
um it's going to take more money and
more resources in a way that
you know in this media environment where
there's so there's only so much money
right and there's only so much you only
ways to
make money um that investment is going
to be really intense it should be really
intense over the next
years to kind of figure out what's going
on in this country because we are at a
it feels like we're at an inflection
point in this country in which
i don't think you know many of the
reports i haven't seen
on 31 um and that most reporters i
talked to who've been doing this for
much longer haven't seen either
yeah um or go ahead eric if you're going
to say something sorry i'm
looking no i i think that i think that's
excellent insight and
you know kind of thinking about a couple
of things directly um
that we've had a chance to kind of
review uh over your reporting you talked
about
uh the black vote um and both trump
and ben getting it wrong um you know in
terms of race in this election you know
obviously
and and uh zach has mentioned this as
well in terms of folks
talking about uh on the democratic side
and using trump being a racist
uh as a narrative it didn't really seem
to stick if we look at the map here
just kind of curious about some of your
thoughts on that yeah i think the thing
that um democrats
do republicans do um in elections
is they hope that one message works for
everyone that looks similar
um they hold it easier that way it's
much easier it's less you spend less
money
you know on a on a kind of cynical level
like it like makes sense right
um and you
in this country where we have the social
economic status of people being so huge
in the way they see and think about the
world
um where they live the kind of access to
health care
their access to um you know
discretionary spending those kinds of
things
you're getting a split in a lot of
places right like obviously
trump was never going to win the black
vote but if the only argument to black
people
is donald trump is a racist you're not
gonna win that right like i talked to a
lot of black people throughout the year
um who what i kept hearing um whether
they were activists or just like normal
people
um was that yeah white people are racist
you know what i mean like that
they just like think that and so it's
like okay so if everybody's racist why
would i go vote for anybody and so you
have
joe biden who the author of the 1994
crime bill that disproportionately
impacted black men in this country
um you know you have so you know
even this year when he was kind of you
know
remembering the good old days in the
senate where he worked with
segregation and he like name check some
people who had terrible views about
black people
these are things like if you put those
two candidates up against each other
there are black people in this country
who i i've talked to there's a lot of
reporting on this
they're like yeah you're all kind of the
same you know what i mean and so you
have to give them something else you
have to give them
something that is um you know what are
you gonna do for me how do you make it
better and i think
you know we started seeing like ice cube
and little wayne
like kind of coming out in very strange
ways little pump
um but the thing that's really funny is
one
just watching that frenzy about around
that
proved that the media and democrats see
black people as democratic when why
would you think why would we think
little wayne
or ice cube are democrats they have
never told us we don't know that you
know what i mean
and so like they're like oh my god why
is lil wayne with donald trump like
maybe he's a republican we don't know he
also can't vote because he's a felon
you know what i mean so it's like you
actually don't know and so
yeah there's this there there are all of
these
um our personal biases and unders
misunderstanding of groups of people
that feed into all of this and it pops
up um
and the and twitter is the worst like
twitter is the place where all of that
is happening the most you know it's just
like
it is a cesspool of an echo chamber of
an echo chamber of an echo chamber like
most americans aren't on there
um and i think that's democrats
you talked about like you know them
getting excited about texas or georgia
and all of those things
that happened a lot on twitter right
like that and if you allow twitter to
run your campaign
you're kind of screwed because that's
not where like real americans are quote
unquote
they're real americans but i mean like
you know like the average american's not
only
american right hillary clinton the
hillary clinton campaign one of the
criticisms there was that they were too
much
listening to the echo chamber it seems
like the joe biden campaign didn't
have not done that right we'll see how
the numbers shake out
but it looks like they played a game
that was based on
what they knew to be true right the
midwest was important he had a chance in
arizona in a way that democrats haven't
had in a very long time
um and ignored he didn't go to texas
they sent kamala harris kind of in the
last days
um he did not go to texas they spent a
lot more money in georgia you know what
i mean than democrats have before
um but they they weren't trying they
weren't concentrating so much on
expanding the map
just using pipe dreams that democrats
have on
how humongous states like texas would go
just off of demographics because just
looking at demographics you don't know
how voters are going to vote sometimes
right the one of the things i thank you
for listening in i hope you enjoyed this
conversation if you did
please do subscribe to yang speaks and
click on notifications so we can let you
know
every time we have a new episode
you